this was this got me in so much trouble
in washington i carried the obamacare
repeal
and i was told by the leadership dude
you can't carry the obamacare appeal and
i'm like you mean the one that you and
everybody else with an herbicide their
name voted for last year and like yeah
because now we have both houses in the
white house so you oh wait hang on i
can't carry it because it might pass yes
and i'm like
oh yeah so this was kabuki theater to
placate a base that they'd think that
they look down their noses out and think
is ignorant um and then when we have the
ability to get it done then they go you
can't do that why not because what what
what then
and
the first day i was in the state senate
i cannot remember the issue but the the
the majority leader is like well what do
we do about this and i said
new guy what about this and he goes
they'll they'll say we're racist and i
said dude they're already saying
what if we just do the right thing and
trust that african americans and
caucasian americans and all americans go
son of a god those guys did the right
thing
you know so like and that was another
thing we talked about all fair like i
cared too much what people said but it
never was able to to to change sort of
what i was gonna do
um you guys are amazing because i've
read the crap they say about you
and and that's that's what happens to
republicans they get cowed into sort of
submitting well that's that's the point
i was making about the armed armory
thing you know that you you could say on
the question of the law as as as the
judge ordered the jury they made the
right call but when you actually break
it down and look at the full story i
mean a gun had been stolen from a car a
gun had been stolen and uh there had
been a string of robberies the neighbors
were scared they were setting up cameras
everywhere the police went door to door
and said here's a picture of the guy
we're looking for someone sees the guy
running down the street surveillance
footage foot caught him in the building
the night before and the guys are like
let's stop him and get the cops so they
call the police but the police said
don't pursue they pursue it anyway dude
they flanked him to the front he runs
after him guy drives behind him filming
he he goes to the to the right around
the truck and then grabs one of the
mcmichael's shotgun they fight for it it
goes off he gets shot in the chest he
dies
now we're in in the case where the
narrative from the left was he was just
jogging he's just jogging what like 20
miles from his own house no no but why
did the mcmichaels grab a gun and go
after him well because a gun had been
stolen and i'm not saying it was the
right thing but the judge basically said
if the law is to be read that you need
to witness the crime then they stopped
him illegally which is a felony and
because he died in the struggle it's
felony murder
yeah right the felony would be um uh
i think false imprisonments imprisonment
kidnapping essentially yeah but the but
the law actually states you have a right
to stop someone if you suspect a felony
well here's the story to me right as a
guy who just got sort of schooled on
this the story to me is that i consider
myself to be marginally well read and
half the stuff you said i'd never heard
that's wild
right i mean you see where i'm going
with this tim right like shout out to
legal insurrection.com and law of self
defense andrew branca because they
actually trained uh trained on self
defense on self defense law in the and
and circumstances under we had a long
phone call in the snow on the way up
here about
this dude's like well if i shoot the
intruder with number four versus double
up buck and i'm like it doesn't matter
you shouldn't it's deadly force anyway
so we don't overthink this we've talked
a lot a lot about that too but but you
know back to the main point it's that
these republicans the ones you mentioned
that they're like oh we can't actually
repeal obamacare because then we have no
i guess you know what no political
animals they took like three or four
votes where they all voted for it and
then i had to do a discharge petition
which is where you try to get a number
of members to sign a bill to get a vote
on it on the floor because the speaker
won't bring it who was a republican wow
and i got like 26 signatures on the
discharge position people wouldn't even
sign the document to let it come to a
vote
because they didn't want to be held
accountable and i'm like like it took me
less than 24 hours to go this place is
broken beyond my ability to repair it
this is why i went back to the ahmed
arbory thing the fox news personalities
and the conservatives who were unwilling
to actually look into it and call it out
because they're scared of being called
racist or whatever yo i got called
racists when i said all of that stuff
and they i'm like i i literally don't
care that you call me that that word has
zero meaning to me or anybody else at
this point
it's well it it's like it's what's worse
that you could call somebody in 2022.
i don't think there's i don't think you
call him anything to be honest but again
that's the point though and and so
but
so i did a radio show for a while and
the last few segments were more or less
on philosophy and the rhetorical
question was if you could choose between
freedom and truth which would you choose
and my answer is you always choose truth
because truth will beget freedom exactly
and the truth is freaking dead
yeah they get to define truth right and
that's that's that's excel series.com
again shameless plug is like did people
know what's going on people demand it's
done done differently you you mentioned
um
republicans saying we can't pass that
they would call us racist
that was a different that was something
the state senate can't even remember
what it was okay but i remember the
majority leader going there well they're
going to say such and such and i'm like
they're already saying it yeah they're
saying worse than that dude but that
come on that that you know
i hear you saying that that was during
the state senate but i have to imagine
that's that's that's everywhere for
republicans so when some series of
african-american women elected
lieutenant governor of virginia and
there was a story in a legitimate
media outlet about how that proved how
racist republicans were like the mental
gymnastics you have to do to get to that
point right i feel that it requires like
a level of uh spiritual toughness to
navigate criticism like this in the
internet age the comments and the the
news articles so like these people can't
do it obviously they tried and failed
they're they're older they're not used
to the internet um like some young
people are i thought i see them as a
vulnerability having individuals there
that can get their morale shattered or
smashed by the the news media so what do
you think about just
eradicating the concept of a bunch of
people going to the capitol building to
vote 700 and and dispersing the
the workload to the american people
so you're talking about an actual
democracy direct amendment or republic
that like we create like a smart
contract that our 700 000 people can
vote to decide if that contract is going
to toggle yes or no for certain things
so we still have some sort of
representative so it still requires that
that more people listen to tim poole's
podcast i mean what i mean by that is
i'm serious though but if without truth
without without a competently informed
intelligent discerning electorate you're
still going to get you're still going to
get bad policy but so so this is uh i i
disagree with ian on this one but it is
a really interesting thought the idea is
instead of doing a direct democracy you
do a direct republic you still have
districts you still have electoral
college but instead of having a
representative it breaks down like an
electoral vote within the state so it
doesn't matter if you know if you have
750 000 people in one area and you have
500 000 in another it's still weighted
you know what i mean
well that yeah so that you get your
senate is the effect thereof but it's
it's hybridized i don't agree with it
you know i i personally think it's good
to have reps there in person doing their
jobs but i do think it's an interesting
idea and i do think that you know as
technology changes and times change we
do need to be addressing how this is
going to affect legislation so
if this is like
you want to fix dc term limits for
staffers
oh yeah yes right not because the
elected there is a bidding war when an
influential member retires over their
chief of staff
and that guy i mean i grew up in the
same neighborhood as a young man a young
man he's older than me who was who'd
been chief of staff for four or five
members great guy like not disparaging
him personally but he had a floor pass
right i mean like this guy's on the
floor of the house more influential by
far than a lot of people who've stood up
for election by 800 thousand of their
constituents so term limits for staffers
once you hit gs 15 in an agency or what
have you you can be there this long and
you got to move because that's where the
secret power is and the second thing is
instead of allowing party leadership
because again political parties are the
poison that will destroy the the mix
to determine committee assignments let
people draw lots for committee
assignments maybe you get you know if
there's 15 committees um maybe you get
15 sheets of paper to put in one bucket
and 14 and 13 and 12 because that's how
they bribe you if you want to be on this
committee ian
sheamus then you have to promise to vote
for the farm bill or not vote for
marijuana reform or what have you and so
in giving the leadership in both the
majority and minority the power to
appoint committees to provide committee
assignments you've just given them the
ability to blackmail every single member
what if you promise it and then don't
follow through with your promise then
you're done like they just won't work
with you they'll all ignore you in
congress there's always retribution for
any time that you betray the hierarchy
it's invisible or it's visible
what would you think because if they
didn't make you pay
everyone would disobey yeah what would
you think about removing party
affiliation from ballots
i don't have a problem with it again i
ran as a republican because it more
closely jived with my value set but my
value said is classical liberalism right
right i was listening to um
to a podcast that you and you were
talking to somebody about um
uh masking and and isolating in order to
preserve the most vulnerable and and my
immediate knee jerk was what is the
responsibility of the most vulnerable to
protect the most vulnerable and my
immediate knee jerk was what's the
responsibility the most vulnerable to
protect themselves amen yeah right and
i'm not saying like being considered
your grandma in fact you should be
really considered your grandma but
grandma's primary responsibility is
grandma right government starts as the
pinpoint center of a circle and radiates
outward from there so the the essence of
government is you then your family then
your neighbors then
yeah yeah the reason i bring up the
party affiliation thing is that uh
people will go into the ballot and
they'll just democrat democrat democrat
democrat they don't know a republican
republican probably it's ignorant on
both ends so imagine what would happen
if people just go in and there's no
party affiliation to vote for it's just
names so you know we've talked about
this before and one response is people
would just vote for whoever's on the top
of the list and then everyone would
fight people people would change their
name to like aaron ardvark yeah well or
people would just vote for somebody if
their name sounded like they were from
the same ethnic background or something
like that like oh that's an irish name
or oh that's an asian name or whatever
someone will change their name but
charizard yeah a bunch of people will
vote guys are going to name it change
his name to lightning and everyone will
be like he's not for crash i'm voting
for this people would like they would
literally
someone like put put it on the bow i'm
not surprised he's like a middle school
kid and he pulled it off yeah wow
but so i there was this there was a
story in um i think it was new hampshire
of a trans anarchist satanist
who ran as a republican for in the sh in
the primary for sheriff and ended up
winning what but but uh i think it was
like the democrat democrat sheriff ended
up winning or something like that but a
bunch of republicans freaked out like i
voted for this person it's like well
yeah you checked the box joke's on you
dummy don't blame the person you voted
for if you voted for voting records so
you didn't know the name of the person
you didn't know what party it was but
you just got to see
all like or a bio you voted for a bio or
something yeah right then the devil
becomes who writes the bio i mean i've
checked my own wikipedia page
like under oath those are like under
oath bios like legal
verified and if you lie on your bio
there you go to prison kind of thing i
think we should let the same people
draft the politifact
like voting for a name or a party is so
insane look at what the media does you
know how they frame things to make them
negative it'll be like you know ian will
run into a burning building to save a
bunch of puppies who are trapped in the
top floor they'll show a picture of ian
standing in the fire holding the puppies
and it'll be like crazed man holds
puppies above flame and you're like well
that's technically true but he was
escaping the fire through the window
they'll just frame it however they want
so you get you know who's gonna write
the bio who's gonna who's gonna write
about the people um it's just like
during
one of my favorite examples of that
occurred during the written house case
when i believe it was grace crits took
the stand
and what they were reporting on i can't
remember which outlet it was but he had
brought a gun of his own to try to
protect himself from written house even
though what he had testified on the
stand was that he pulled a gun on kyle
before getting shot that yeah and he
lied and msnbc they were like he
testified that rittenhouse pulled the
weapon on him and then it was like
actually he testified he testified he
pulled the gun on written house and then
written house pointed the weapon so it's
just like the media just chooses to say
whatever they want because
i i don't think it's necessarily times v
sullivan that gives them this power the
fact is lawsuits are
very hard and they take
forever
and so look at it this way
they say sometimes they say often for a
lot of cops process is the punishment
new york city is notorious for this the
cops know they can illegally arrest you
but nothing will ever be done about it
so there's nothing to worry about so uh
a good example is there was a
photographer in new york by the name of
alex arbuckle he was standing on the
sidewalk taking pictures of cops during
an occupy protest he actually had gone
down there to document it from the
police's side of things because he felt
the media was only covering the protest
perspective the police arrested him
filed a false police report and claimed
that he was obstructing a roadway the
officer who actually arrested him wasn't
the officer who claimed to have arrested
him and who had signed the arrest report
and the officer who wrote the who who
signed the arrest report wrote a fake
account of what happened fortunately i
had been filming
and uh the national lawyers guild i'm
not big fans of them but they got a hold
of the footage which proved the police
lied
the police officer went on the stand and
lied under oath
not a single bad thing happened to any
of these officers
but the cops know
if you're in their way they can arrest
you and you will go to jail even if for
only a day because that is the
punishment for defying them they know it
can destroy your life they know it can
you can get fired from your job if you
can't show up if they arrest you on a
weekend when you're protesting you're
there till monday
they know so this is this is a huge
problem we have when
lawsuits in this country move much too
slowly so someone lies about you and you
know says like ian you know you kicked
my dog okay go ahead and sue him the
story's out it will perpetuate
so uh let's let's say there's a news
website called like the daily uh monster
the daily monster
and they write a hit piece about you
claiming that uh you stole someone's cat
oh and it's completely made up can you
imagine the most made up and insane
story and you know people you know so
you're like okay maybe i should sue for
defamation over this knife first you
gotta prove damn proof damages what were
the real damages caused by this well
what they've done to project veritas is
they've said his reputation is so
destroyed he's he's you know he you
can't make his you can't make his
reputation any worse thus we're now
allowed to lie and say whatever we want
a court rejected that idea but they
destroy your character so much
that you eventually you won't be able to
fundraise you won't be able to start a
business you won't be able to get
business partners people will be
terrified of you so you say i need to
sue over these lies the first thing that
happens is the court says times v
sullivan ian you're a public figure did
they know they were lying or you know uh
did their stand did their standard in
this procedure violate their typical
standards is my general understanding
for uh times v sullivan let's say you
get past all of that you got to get to
actual malice too right so their defense
says well we didn't know therefore they
win well exactly that's times v sullivan
as a public figure
it's um proving they knew they were
lying or
that what they did in this instance
violated their typical standards for
research
so if you can get past that
bro it's going to take you a million
dollars in a year
and then if you can't prove you lost
money because of it they're going to ask
you what are the damages and you can say
reputational my reputation is my
business and they can say prove it
there you you lose so it's not just
times view sullivan it's that
the media can lie with impunity and
nothing can be done about it nothing and
they do it all day they do it every day
they did it
you know seven days a week and twice on
sunday when it came to donald trump and
what do you do so like if i make a lie
like that am i do i have protections or
do i need to start a company called like
aardvark news and then just a website
aardvark news and then lie about you
under aardvark news and then i then i
have protection because i made a website
called aardvark news all that matters
is
you can defend yourself from a lawsuit
so when cnn are these big companies new
york times have billions of dollars they
will drop a an anvil on you
metaphorically
so
i hope you're ready to defend yourself
can you do the same back
probably not probably not so project
veritas
has veritas legal where they're trying
that's a problem it's this this
attrition the war of attrition when you
are plan on losing anyway you just want
to drain the resources of the other
person and you know you have way more
resources so you can just wait them out
and you may still lose but they're gonna
like a pyrrhic victory they might win on
paper but because it's the percentage of
their army has been decimated they've
basically lost have you guys ever played
poker hold them oh yeah yeah if you're
if any if you know hold'em if you've got
the stack
you can you can pressure your opponent
yeah endlessly and force them out that's
exactly how it is in the real world you
put them all in every hand every hand
say you gotta risk everything you have
right now and i don't and i can do it
again seven times
and you're just man and they're putting
in the blinds and eventually they're
getting eaten away and they've got to
take that risk and then they take the
wrong risk and they're out but you can
also win in those situations and man
does it feel good to take someone's
stack it does it does but if you're if
you know if you're the last two in a
game of hold'em and and you've got a
smaller stack to the guy's bigger stack
lines are going up yeah eventually the
blind is going to be your entire just a
play you're going to have to bet
everything
yeah so this is this is the challenge
hatchet harry's going to take your dad's
bar you know that's right you're gonna
have to like throw your wedding ring
into the middle of the thing and then
the deed to your house well i have gems
but that's that's the big challenge is
as long as the media can just lie and
say whatever they want we we we stop all
this by not caring what the media is i
don't know i also think we need to
change the laws it used to be that there
was some you know responsibility in nbc
cbs and abc that was it new york times
now it's joey joey macaroni or i'm sorry
if joey if you're out there and he's
just making up a name
get started
sorry joey i love you come on there
there are clever things you can do into
your question about starting aardvark
news or whatever and you probably said
arvak news because i mentioned aaron
earlier oh that's why yeah but uh
so ian if you start a news organization
they'll still just see you personally
and you may have a good chance of
winning
but you better fork up the 100k for that
initial defense so if someone at cnn
lies about you you can sue the person
that lied directly and not cnn yep
is that normally what happens you can
sue anyone joining them all but do you
have a better chance of winning against
the individual reporter or the
entitlement entirely depends but uh you
can go after the individual and then
they can try and deflect typically what
will happen is the institution will
offer up the defense force can you sue
the institution and the individual at
the same time yeah yep so uh cassandra
fairbanks a good friend of ours she held
up the okay hand sign in the white house
which is just the trump you know you
know hey we're trump supporters and a
reporter accused her of flashing a white
supremacy hand gesture she said that's
not true it's defamation she filed a
suit it got thrown out on a motion to
dismiss i guess because they're like
like you yes i think what they said was
because she trolls on twitter then you
can't blame someone for believing you're
trolling or something for for falling
for a troll or something like that yeah
but it's just the the news organization
defended the journalist the news
organization said we're going to pay for
the journalists defense so the
individuals who work for these big
companies with hundreds of millions of
dollars can say what they want and they
get away with it yeah exactly and so ian
you were sort of talking about possible
legal solutions a moment ago i think the
fact of the matter is even though
something like that would be good in
specific instances and there are really
great victory stories we were discussing
sandman yesterday
we've also been hearing that written
house is trying to go after some of
these networks that lied about him i
think that's fantastic but ultimately
people are waking up and there's a
reason that they have to write pieces
and hit pieces on people like joe rogan
or tim and that's because old media is
scared because people are paying more
attention to independent content
creators and one of the reasons for that
is because it's insane to get your
information from people who pay no price
for lying to you walk the dog backwards
to the genesis right and and so the
genesis i think is what they teach in j
school and who decides to be journalists
what's the role of the journalist
because jefferson talked about that that
fourth state and and the importance of
information to uh a free public like
there can't be one without the other uh
and so we've gotten away from i want to
be a storyteller to i want to be an
advocate i want to advance an agenda and
so
um what did
get off air you know aristotle
repeatedly said you give me the
storytellers i'll give you the future
dude these guys have studied on what
they're trying to do
and a lot of the parts of the machine
don't even realize they're parts of the
machine but indeed they are when you
the the individuals these companies
don't know
uh what happens is there's a political
group and they'll say how can we get
more votes we need new stories in our
favor can we fund a news organization
yes the news organization then hires
people these people are business people
who want to make money they're told
here's our plan for making money hire
people who believe x y and z they then
go and fight find journalists who have
written stories about x y and z and say
how would you like a higher paying job
they get higher under the company no one
forces them to be cogs in the machine no
one forces them to write lies they find
people who are liars and idiots and hire
them and have them do more work or
they're not liars they they've drank the
proverbial drunk of the proverbial
kool-aid they just genuinely believe it
but like
your your formative years include your
higher ed right so university of
missouri and columbia these jay schools
syracuse that put out like a
disproportionate share the orthodoxy is
in place yeah right and and dude man i
didn't become comfortable in my
dorkiness until i was 25 or later right
and i am now like i am who i am and i
like me would you know um
[Music]
these kids are are vulnerable so people
are saying this is it and there's
nothing else and they go okay this is it
there's nothing else yeah it's funny you
just mentioned a moment ago that some of
these people might not necessarily be
lying but they're on the same page as of
all is all of their colleagues and
that's unsurprising but at the same time
there was a great moment from chomsky
who i'm not a huge fan of but he made a
point when he was on an interview show
about how the dominant media culture
tends to do a spouse a specific set of
views and you can expect to hear a
certain number of you know legitimized
opinions from them and the reporter
responds to him by asking him do you
believe i'm insincere in my values and
chomsky said no i believe you sincerely
hold those i'm telling you you wouldn't
have this job if you didn't that's
brilliant yeah yep
yeah chomsky also said in the arena of
violence the uh the most brutal wins and
that's not us
when he was condemning that's right
violence and writing so you know the
dude lost the plot later on but he was
pretty good back in the day too he's a
free speech guy i mean he's made some
good noises over here again not my
favorite not my favorite but he's made
some good noises yeah
like quack
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time